بوتين في اوكرانيا لاول مره منذ العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في زياره لمدينه مريوطن
ويلتقي كبار القاده العسكريين
تحركات جمهوريه ضد اعتقال ترامب وشرطه
نيويورك تتاهب الاحتجاجات المحتمله
الثلاثاء
وفي فرنسا نقابات تتوعد الحكومه بتوسيع
اضراباتها لتشمل قطعي الطيران والتعليم
غدا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر بدايه
هذه النشره من روسيا التي اعلن الكريمان
فيها ان الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين قام بزياره
مدينه ماريوبل الاوكرانيه لاول مره منذ
بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا وقيل بانه تجول في المدينه
بسياره وتفقد مناطقها وتحدث الى عدد من
السكان كما التقى قاده عسكريين في روستوف
في جنوب روسيا قاده العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه على كل حال المزيد من التفاصيل
حول هذه الزياره التي اعلن عنها ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبر
الهاتف موسكو عبد الجواد ماذا نعرف عن
تفاصيل هذه الزياره
صباح الخير ابراهيم معك في الحق يعني
الكريملين يقوم بنشر بياني يتحدث عن ان
توتين يعني
قام بالوصول الى مرض عبر الطائره مروحيه
ومن ثم قام طبعا بقياده سياره بنفسه
والتجول في بعض الشوارع المدينه والحديث
الى بعض السكر نعم يعني هي خطوه غير
مسبوقه منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه الان
في ماربل وهما والجميع يعرف ان ماريوبل
ذات اهميه استراتيجيه وكانت قد خاضت ام
المعارك مع الجانب الاوكراني في تلك
المنطقه طبعا البيان تطرق يعني منذ نحو
نصف ساعه من الان الى ان هذه الزياره هي
زياره عمل كما سماها هذا البيان هي مدينه
ماريوبل
تحدث مع السكان حول الوضع في المدينه حول
ما يحتاجونه حول الخدمات اللوجستيه حول
عمليه اعاده الاعمار وغير من المواضيع
طبعا زياره الماريوتل والتي هي تبتعد
قرابه يعني 80 كيلومترا عن الحدود السابقه
للاراضي الروسيه عن نهر الدون هناك طبعا
مع مركز القياده ابراهيم في
تقرير من رئيس هيئه الاركان العام الروسيه
دراسه والذي يعتبر الان قائد العمليه
العسكريه هناك الاراضي الاوكرانيه طبعا
ابراهيم هو يعني قد نشهد خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه وبعض التحليلات السياسيه
داخل البلاد تتحدث عن انها قد تكون
القرار الذي خرج ومذكره الاعتقال لبوتين
من جهه من جهه خطوه دعم بعد توقيع قرار
يوم امس يمنع يعني تشويه سمعه العمليه
العسكريه ومن يشارك بها في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لذلك طبعا ابراهيميه خطوه غير
مسبوقه قد تحظى بشعبيه كبيره قد تحظى
بتعليقات كثيره على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هي ساعات قليله وسيظهر طبعا
التحليل السياسي في البلاد حول هذا
الموضوع
بانه نائب رئيس الوزراء ابلغ الرئيس عن
التقدم المحرز في عمليات البناء واعاده
ترميم بالمدينه ومحيطه وكان روسيا تود ان
توصل للعالم رساله بانها تعيد اعمار
ماريوبل لتبقى فيها وانها لن تخرج منها
كيف يمكن فهم ما جاء في بيان الكرملين حول
هذه النقطه تحديدا
ابراهيم طبعا في البدايه اسمح لي انا اقول
بان العربيه يعني كانت هي اول كاميرا قد
وصلت الى ماريوبل خلال البدء بعمليه
الاعمار هذه العمليه بدات منذ الصيف
الماضي بعد انتهاء الحرب هناك لكن طبعا
عمليه الاعمار
عباره عن
منار في
المدينه باعتبار ان قرابه 80% من المدينه
هو مهدم نوعا ما ولا يوجد فيها ابنيه لم
تتضرر من الحرب لذلك طبعا لم يتطرق
بالحديث بالتفاصيل عن عمليه اعاده الاعمار
لكن ابراهيم كما تحدثت بانها لن تقوم بترك
هذه المناطق التي سيطرت عليها في جنوب
الاوكراني وقد ضمتها يعني اليوم الكثير من
المواطنين في ماري اصبحوا يحملون الجوازات
الداخليه الروسيه والهويه ويعني اصبحوا
داخل النظام الروسي موسكو هو ذاهبه يعني
نحو تجنيس باقي هؤلاء المواطنين في تلك
المناطق لذلك طبعا اصبحت تعتبر بانما وهذه
المنطقه التي تجاره فيها حرب طويله هي ارض
روسيه بعد ان ضمتها كما يذكر الجميع
الخريف الماضيه تم ضمها في مايو الماضي في
شهر مايو سيكون هناك
عام على ربما ضم هذه المدينه تحدثت عن
موضوع السكان المحليين للمدينه هناك
الكثير منهم يؤيدون روسيا لكن حجم
المؤيدين
للعوده الى اوكرانيا كم هو والى اما هناك
ربما قبول بهذا الواقع الجديد الذي
رسمته موسكو
ابراهيم يعني لابد من لفت الانتباه بان
الكثير من المواطنين الاوكرانيين الاصل
كانوا قد خرجوا من ماريوبل نحو الغرب يعني
من تنضم النسبه الاكبر في التي بقيت في
المدينه هون من المواطنين يعني الروس هم
اصليون يعني كما تقول التقارير في تلك
المنطقه لذلك طبعا عمليه الجسم في عمليه
تجنيس هؤلاء المواطنين وبنحهم الجنسيه
الروسيه ضمت شريحه واسعه لكن حتى اليوم
ابراهيم كما نلاحظ في التقارير بان موسكو
لا تقوم بفرض هذه الجنسيه على جميع
المواطنين هي كانت قدمت خيارا بانما يريد
البقاء على جنسيته الاوكرانيه يعني يمكنه
فعل هذا لكن هذا الشيء يعني لن يمكنه من
الاستفاده من كافه المواضيع التي قد تقوم
باقامتها موسكو في ماريوبل وفي ضواحيها
وفي مناطق اخرى طبعا لابد من عمليه تجنيس
مواطني
في المدينه
بشكل اساسي ابراهيم باعتبار ان المدينه هي
مهذبه نوعا ما لذلك الموضوع يجري في مناطق
نحو الجهه الشرقيه في
الغربيه في ميليتوبل وغيرها من المدن التي
انقطاع التي لم تتعرض لعمليات تدمير ويعني
تعمل يعمل فيها النظام اللوجي لذلك
موجات كثيره من نزوح السكان نحو مناطق
مختلفه العديد منهم ذهب الى
الداخل الروسي الى رستوفو من هناك كما
توزيعه الى مره اخرى والبعض الاخر طبعا
التعبير الموالي لاوكرانيا قامت طبعا
بالهجره والنزوح الى مناطق الغرب والبعض
منهم طبعا اصبح في الدول الاوروبيه معروفه
بالنسبه نزوح الى هناك ابراهيم عبد الجواد
ذكرت في بدايه مداخلتك معي بانه
تزامنت زياره الرئيس الروسي الى مريول
وتاتي غداه اعلان روسيا بانها ستجرب
انتقاد الجيش برايك التقاء الرئيس الروسي
بكبار قاده عمليته العسكريه ومن بينهم
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه في ري جرسيموف
الي مدى يمثل رساله داخليه لقوات فاغن
التي كانت المنتقد الاكبر لهذه القوات
وايضا الى الخارج بان الجيش الروسي يحظى
بدعم بوتين الكامل
ابراهيم يعني هذا موضوع يعني له حساسيه
اليوم في الداخل الروسي لكن قرارات
الكرملين حسمت كل الموضوع يوم امس من جهه
طبعا تحدثت عن ضروره وان القانون الروسي
سيقوم بمعاقبه من ينتقد او يشوه العمليه
العسكريه او من يشارك بها وتحت هذا
القانون طبعا تدخل قوه فاغنر ابراهيم يعني
مهما زادت الخلاف ومهما زادت الانتقادات
بين ظفر ووزاره الدفاع الا ان يعني
الموضوع ابراهيم لا يحتاج للكثير من
القراءه
العسكريه والقراءه السياسيه لمعرفه
وللوقوف على ان ظاهر انهم تعمل تحت جناحها
وزاره الدفاع تخيل ابراهيم يعني
يعني
قوات خاصه لاتحام والسيطره على المدن
لكنها تحظى بدعم وزاره الدفاع بما يخص
عمليه الطيران المقاتلات المروحيات
كضاربات الصواريخ المدفعيه ان كانت قريبه
المدى او بعيده المدى لذلك طبعا قام بسكوف
يوم امس بالحديث عن ان من سيقوم بانتخابنر
ايضا سيتعرض للمساءله قانونيه حول هذا
الموضوع يعني
اصبح يعني الحديث به على العلم ابراهيم
ولكن طبعا لم يتم الاشاره الى ان قوات
فاغنر تعتبر احد قوات الجيش الروسي هذه هي
النقطه الوحيده لذلك طبعا ابراهيم وجود
كتم اليوم وحديثه مع هؤلاء
العسكريين القاره طبعا للعمليه العسكريه
هو خطوه دعم لهم من جهه لكن في الاخير
يعني يبقى
قديره يعني هم يعني الرجال حول قوتين في
نهايه المطاف مما يخص اقتحام المدن كان قد
عمل كثيرا على تطوير هذه القوات الخاصه
الشيشانيه الداغستانيه وغيرها مثل هذه
المهمات الاقتحام المدن اما الجيش الروسي
ابراهيم حتى هذه اللحظه فهو طبعا يعمل على
الاداره اللوجستيه على موضوع الطيران على
موضوع الصواريخ القذائف والمدفعيه والامور
اللوجستيه بما في ذلك تصوير الاقمار
الصناعيه وتقديم الخطط ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا
على كل هذه المعلومات والاحاطه من موسكو
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد كنت معنا عبر
الهاتف شكرا جزيلا لك
كشفت مجله الامريكيه ان خطه النيتو لتجهيز
قوات مستعده للقتال تصل الى 300 الف شخص
بالقربي من الحدود مع روسيا يمكن ان تقوض
وحده الحلف بسبب التكاليف الباهظه
لتنفيذها وان نقص الاموال والذخائر يعقد
الوضع واشاره المجله الى ان اعداد او
اعداد مثل هذا العدد من الجنود يتطلب مئات
الالاف من انواع الذخيره المختلفه وسيتعين
على دول الناتو المشاركه في توفير الجنود
والطائرات والسفن والدبابات ولفت
الكوريتيكو الى ان هناك خطر من عدم تمكن
جميع اعضاء الحلف من الوفاء بوعودهم
بالمساهمه في خطه النيتو الدفاعيه
حضر رئيس اوكرانيا الدول التي تساعد روسيا
ضد بلاده بان مصيرها العزله في العالم ولم
يحدد زيلينسكي في كلمه مسجله بثها عبر
حسابه على تويتر اسماء تلك الدول لكنه قال
ان من ضمنها دوله تزود روسيا بطائرات
مسيره من نوع شاهد التي تنتجها ايران
واضافه الرئيس الاوكراني بان هناك مساعدات
عسكريه جديده تشمل ذخائر ودبابات مدافع
قادمه لبلاده من كندا والمانيا وفرنسا
والدنمارك واستونيا
تواصل اوساط رسميه والشعبيه في روسيا
رفضها المطلق لقرار محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه حول اصدار مذكره اعتقال بحق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على خلفيه
الصراع الاوكرانيه
صراع عبد الاصابع بين موسكو والغرب يتحول
الى كسر عظام بين الطرفين بعد مذكره
اعتقال من الجنايات الدوليه تنال من زعيم
الكرملين مقامره غير محسوبه قابلت روسيا
حتى الان بالتقليل من شان هذه الخطوه
كونها غير معنيه بمحكمه لا تعترف بها
الرد غير ممكن على جنون الغرب وتصرفهم غير
عقلاني وهذا يعكس مرضهم العقلي المحكمه
الجنائيه لا تعترف بها لاموسكو ولا واشنطن
لذلك مناقشه القرار شيء فارغ نحن نفتخر
بزعيمنا العظيم على العالم ان يعرف هذا
الكثير يا سياتي في البلاد تحدث اصدار
مذكرات الاعتقالي تم توقيتها مع زياره
الزعيم الصيني الى موسكو في العشرين من
الشهر الجاري زياره ترى فيها موسكو خطوه
هامه ورساله للغرب حول ولاده من الخاصره
لقطبي جديد في العالم كله يناسب
لن يكون لدينا رئيس هذا شيء مضحك نستنكر
هذا القرار طبعا
لا يمكنني تصور تبعات هذا القرار ما يهمني
كيف سيكون المستقبل خاصه مع زياره الرئيس
الصيني وكيف سيتصرف دبلوماسيون حيال هذا
المذكره تعكس انفصاما في تركيبه لولايات
المتحده وقرارات المحكمه باطله ولا معنى
لها بالنسبه لروسيا قرار محكمه لاهارا
ومكان الوثيقه مع محارم المهملات بهذه
الطريقه وصفت موسكو مذكره اعتقالي زعيم
الكرملين عبد الجواد الروشت العربيه موسكو
اعتبر رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفما
كارتي ان المدع العام في منهات يسيء
استخدام السلطه ويسعى لانتقام سياسي من
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دورون ترامب حيث
نشر تغريده عبر حسابه في تويتر تحدث فيها
عن اساءه استخدام السلطه من قبل المدعي
العام في منهات الذي يسمح للمجرمين
بالتجوال بينما يسعى للانتقام السياسي من
الرئيس ترامب واشارتي لانه يقوم بتوجيه
لجان ذات الصله للتحقيق على الفور مما اذا
كانت الاموال الفيدراليه تستخدم لتخريب
الديمقراطيه عبر التدخل في الانتخابات من
خلال الملاحقات القضائيه ذات الدوافع
السياسيه
دونالد ترامب في قلب العاصفه من جديد لكن
الرياح لا تجري بما لا يشتهيه الرئيس
الامريكي السابق فحسب بل تهدد سفينته
بالغرق هذه المره
سيتم توقيف المرشح الجمهوري الرئيسي
والرئيس السابق للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الثلاثاء تظاهروا واستعيدوا
بلادنا بهذه الكلمات اعلنت ترامب عبر منصه
تروس توقعه بالقاء القبض عليه يوم
الثلاثاء في منهاتا خلال مثوله امام
المحكمه وحس انصاره على الاحتجاج لكن مدير
مكتبه اعلن انه لم يتلقى اي اخطار من
المدعي العام باعتقاله وان تصريحات الرئيس
مبنيه على تسريبات مكتب المدعي العام في
نيويورك استدعى ترامب للادلاء بشهادته في
قضيه دفع مبالغ ماليه لممثله الافلام
الاباحيه
قبل ايام ما يعني حتميه توجيه اتهامات
جنائيه ضده
الاشاعات عن العلاقه بين ترامبو دانالز
خرجت قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2016
لكن صحيفه
نشرت تقريرا في عام 2018 عن مال دفعه
محامي تراب مايكل
كوهينز مقابل صمتها يقدر ب 130 الف دولار
وباعتبار ان المبلغ تم دفعه قبل شهر من
موعد الانتخابات يحاجج منتقد ترامب بان
هذا المال قد يمثل خرقا لقوانين الحمله
الانتخابيه فهل سيتم اعتقال ترامب حقا
ليكون اول رئيس امريكي يعتقل في تاريخ
البلاد بلال البجديدي العربيه
اكدت اداره شرطه نيويورك لوكاله نوبل في
انها في حاله تاهب واستعداد لمواجهه اي
احتجاجات محتمله على خلفيه نداء وجهه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
لمناصريه ودعوته لهم للاحتجاج واضافت شرطه
نيويورك بانها ستبقى على اتصال وتنسيق مع
شركائها في الحكومه واجهزه انفاذ القانون
للمحافظه على السلامه العامه وكانت وسائل
الاعلام ذكرت ان ترامب قد يواجه اتهامات
الاسبوع المقبل فيما يتعلق بدفع اموال
لممثله الافلام الاباحيه مقابل التزامها
الصمت بشان علاقتها المزعومه الا ان
الرئيس السابق دور ترامب نفر العلاقه معها
واي اعمال غير قانونيه ورفض الادلاء
بشهادته امام هيئه المحلفين كما انتقد
ترامب مكتب المدعي العام بمنطقه منهات
واصفا اياه بالفاسد والمسيس للغايه
قلع عضو مجلس السياده السودانيه سلعه انه
لا مكان لفتره انتقاليه فيما سماه ابتزازا
من جانب الميليشيات والقوى المسلحه في
البلاد ونقل بيان للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه عن العطاء قوله انه لن يتم
السماح بابتزاز اي قائد للدوله ومؤسساتها
بامتلاكه جيشا واضاف العطاء بان الفتره
الانتقاليه وقيادتها يجب الا تتعرض
للابتزاز بوجود جيوش وميليشيات خارج
سيادتها مشيرا الى ان الجيش السوداني قادر
على حسم اي تهديد داخلي او خارجي معتبرا
ان الجيش السوداني لا يستخدم تكتيكات
للاستمرار في الحكم وشدد العطاء انه لا بد
من تحقيق الاستقرار في البلاد عبر قدر
اكبر من التوافق الوطني من القوى المدنيه
والمكون العسكري
رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح
البرهان قال ان الجيش سيدعم الحكومه
المدنيه المقبله مؤكدا ان القوات المسلحه
عفوا لن تتخلى عن واجباتها
نحن عندنا اليات وعندنا
تنظيمات وجهات مسؤوله من تنفيذ مظالم
الناس
نحن بنعلى مستوى انه كل مشكله بتتحل
وبتتعالج بورق بكتابه اذا كان تعديل لا
قوانين لروائح لنظم لكل شيء ده حق الناس
نحن ما نتاخر فيه ولا حنجيب فيه مما جينا
سمعنا هتاف الناس وسمعنا كلام الناس انه
جيش واحد شعب واحد حق الجيش ده حقكم انتم
ما حق اي زول ثاني ولا احد جانا ولا حق
زيد ولا حق عبيد عشان كذا لما قلنا هنجيب
الاسعافات هنجيبه من الجيش
العبارات حتقطع الناس حنجيبها من الجيش
القلابات هنجيب لنا قلابات اربعه قلابات
وحنجيب لوادر حنجيبهم من الجيش يعني الناس
هنا
اكدت اطراف غير موقعه على الاتفاق الاطاري
في السودان خلال لقاء معناه برئيس مجلس
السياده محمد حمدان رغبتها في التوصل الى
توافق حول الترتيبات اللازمه لاستكمال
عمليه السياسيه في البلاد وقالت قوات
الدعم السريع في بيان ان الجانبين ناقشه
اخر التطورات السياسيه في ضوء مخرجات
الاجتماع الاخير مع الاطراف الموقعه على
الاتفاق الاطري واضف البيان بان الاطراف
غير الموقعه على الاتفاق الاطاري طالب
الدقلب بمواصله مساعيه لتقريب وجهات النظر
والتوصل لاتفاق سياسي
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعونا فيها بعض الفاصل
كندا تسون اجراءات تسهل تمديد اقامه
السوريين والاتراك على اراضيها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد افاده مراسل العربيه بان
الشرطه الفرنسيه اعتقلت 80 متظاهرا في
باريس باحتجاجات تخللتها اعمال شغب
واشتباكات مع الشرطه لليوم الثاني على
التوالي واستخدمت شرطه مكافحه الشغب الغاز
المسائل للدموع لتفريق المتظاهرين واشتبكت
مع بعضهم بعد اشعال النار في صناديق
القمامه وتمثل الضرابات المتزايده اخطر
تحدي لسلطه الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
وحكومته السعيه الى تمرير مشروع اصلاح
لنظام التقاعد برفعه عامين الى سن اربعه
وستين عاما
اعلن نائب رئيس تركيا ارتفاع حصيله وفاه
زلزال تركيا الى تسعه واربعين الفائته
مشيرا الى ان من بينهم سته الاف وثمانمائه
وسبعه من المواطنين الاجانب واكد ان
الحكومه التركيه ستعالج الاضرار التي
سببها الزلزال باسرع وقت ممكن حيث يتم
التخطيط لبناء 610 الاف منزل وتسليمها
لاصحابها الشرعيين
منظمه الصحه العالميه الصين على نشر كل
المعلومات المتعلقه باصل جائحه كورونا بعد
نشر نتائج جديده لفتره وجيزه على قاعده
بيانات دوليه تستخدم لتتبع مسببات الامراض
وقال المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
تدرس ادهم ان هذه المعلومات تمثل خيطا
جديدا في التحقيق في اصول كورونا ويتعين
تقاسمها على الفور
في نهايه نشر نذكره بابرز ما جاء فيها من
عناوين
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في اوكرانيا
لاول مره منذ العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
زياره لمدينه مريوبل التقى خلالها كبار
القاده العسكريين
تحركات جمهوريه ضد اعتقالي الرئيس السابق
ترامب وشرطه نيويورك تتاهب الاحتجاجات
محتمله يوم الثلاثاء
وفي فرنسا نقابات تتوعد الحكومه بتوسيع
اضراباتها لتشمل قطاع الطيران والتعليم
يوم غدا
نهايه شكرا لكم متابعه والى اللقاء عند
منتصف
[موسيقى]